hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba don't think you've ever
seen me before
no knows I'm introducing Sally Lomonaco
here to the channel right now how are
you Sally I'm good how are you good is
the first time we're catching up all day
today so we like to catch up on camera
because we have no personal life didn't
know I'm not thinking about time right
now we're gonna check out a video that
was sent over to us it's just a fun one
to do I figured why not start off with a
fun one when Sally this might not be the
first one that's uploaded but it's the
first one we're shooting ultimate Mike
drops of the internet vol 1 2-minute
account of me I feel like this is a
series I could go on forever it's a
great concept
keep it going this is from the channel
rapid 6go subscribing them right away
and go check out Sally's channel she
just put up a video recently I did I'm
not in it I almost put you in my intro
thanks well I learned it's 2018 this
guy's a dick alright let's let's do this
the prior car wasn't recording yeah out
of context
[Music]
[Music]
there could be an infinite number of
parallel universes does that mean that
there was a universe out there where I
am smarter than you I've seen this
interview well you were like the carrot
top of interviewers no no cry no cry
after the interviews over because
otherwise I look like it was responsible
for okay so well I don't want to do that
no my interview dress up as herself with
an app like a Raging [ __ ] what about
you as you speak your mind and you don't
use a politician's filter without its
downsides in particular when it comes to
women you call women you don't like fat
pigs dogs slobs and disgusting animals
do you think that was like trash and the
president of something
it's worse than that for people
everyone's got an iPhone you know Hey
look no I can't say that so say he's
gone they still came up with another one
right
can I just have you say my name into the
camera just the word Romina what's gonna
happen to know like what to get it like
if we just broke up I couldn't say
anything minute you're trying to find me
in a crowded place okay
Romina the thing is I actually didn't
want to find you after getting a
subpoena and then us in Washington as
you would say very expensive process
prosecutor and because you know what
people have been their lives have been
destroyed for doing one fifth of what
you've done and it's a disgrace
everything he just said is absolutely
false but I'm not surprised in the first
debate because you know it's just
awfully good that someone with the
temperament of Donald Trump is not in
charge of the law in our country because
you'd be in jail secretary this guy
likes his campaign how do you respond to
that
like that would you really is it for you
to do something like this was it more
nervous for you to box
oh my god it's actually not cool to be a
victim there's no value in being a
victim you win no awards for being a
victim molester Colin Kaepernick you
tweet very musingly I wish you did know
you sent me they must know because
they're probably following you on
Twitter you can't even pay attention
you're a terrible interviewer yeah
that's why your job
[Applause]
a basketball
[Applause]
[Music]
no gender is not disconnected from sex
oh okay no it is not in the mind okay
you're not a man if you think here man
and I didn't say pretending or if I did
I shouldn't say pretending let me amend
right okay I said a boy who thinks he's
a girl let's see the usual phraseology I
use not playing I usually say a boy who
thinks she'd roll over things to the
point which is technically what we're
talking about here as far as the actual
psychological issues at play and it used
to be called gender dysphoria or gender
identity disorder another college gender
dysphoria the idea that that sex or
gender are malleable is not true okay
and I'm not denying your humanity if you
are transgender person I am saying that
you are not the sex to which you claim
to be you're still a human being and
you're a human being with an issue that
I'm you know I wish you Godspeed in
dealing with in whatever way you see fit
but if you are going to dictate to me
that I'm supposed to pretend I'm
supposed to pretend and then on women in
women are men no my answer is no I'm not
going to I'm not going to modify basic
biology because it threatens your
subjective sense of what you are
I'm saying that the Boy Scouts have a
standard you must be a biological boy to
be able West you have to be a point to
be a Boy Scout Boy Scouts things you can
never remember all the countries are so
it's always fun to discover a new age so
that means then that we then in their
twenties attendance because the Assembly
members have decided
[Music]
[Applause]
people think that you can solve
catholics have to talk about
I actually was trained in calculus every
year yeah I'm a neuroscience
I'm sue this interview
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
when you ride a motorcycle you have to
be a defensive defensive driver you
don't have time to talk on the phone to
eat you know tell do a lot of things
most people do every single day which is
more dangerous than riding also have to
really be focused on see any traffic
ahead he doesn't know about this he's
never ridden a motorcycle you never
understand what it takes to be a winner
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm a business development manager
absolutely not no it's interesting to me
but I'm sure that it would probably go
right over your head um Doris so when
she missed the questions you took up a
larger amount of time than necessary and
other things I'd like to take my time
[Applause]
you don't have to go to college it may
not be for you I get that it may not be
for you but if you're going to be in
this world you pull your own weight had
a long haul from where
from to here but here we are
so truth was in the proof of the pudding
is in the eating and here we sit at the
diner table but it's hard to when you
say that to some people because they say
oh there you go with a pull yourself up
by the bootstraps thing and you know
you're just being respectable not
everybody can do that what everybody can
can would it be funny yeah of course
well you guys just [ __ ] grow up and
just sit down and write your own
horseshit and come up with it start your
own [ __ ] show up your own award show
good waiting around for other people to
do [ __ ] for you that's the [ __ ]
problem
if you guys had your own big Club and I
was standing outside of it you'd never
[ __ ] let me in I'd stop my own [ __ ]
you guys got to start your own [ __ ] you
got brains in there right yes absolutely
so write your own [ __ ] you put your
[ __ ] wine and we're all leaving the
giant [ __ ] sandwich out here nobody
cares I don't care what was the last
time you went on stage you killed so
hard the person after you bond if you're
[ __ ] doing that on a regular basis
people are gonna notice regardless of
what you have between your legs so they
didn't cancel you you can still go
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] we get one complaint
and we get kicked out this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] plus if you're gonna be a
landlord and brighten the game kappa no
love UK maybe try not be a [ __ ]
prejudiced piece of [ __ ] how about that
I could buy this house [ __ ] need you
[Music]
I don't think it'd work you're saying
that you don't think that God has a
sense of humor
[Music]
[Music]
well you should watch this movie called
inherit the wind
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
why'd she go did she go thanks to John I
I should rephrase that I think it's a
class trailer
[Music]
Wow it was a mixture of funny and like
loud definitely there's also some
there's some Republican and liberal
point of views in here it was smart to
mix it up I think you guys are sometime
for interviews where you're like okay
that's definitely like you got different
political sides here for sure that was
smart to mix it up instead of just
having it one agenda that way everyone
could enjoy this video leave politics
out of my youtube videos that interview
with Jesse Eisenberg I have a theory
about the way you see it's a setup
yeah when I first thought I didn't think
so but then I was like they needed
something to push that second movie and
like that was funny when that first came
out everyone was watching it it's the
way she acts I feel like if it were
actually like I'm IRA in that position I
would not have been so slick with my
responses and I would know I kept egging
him on that was my job as a journalist
and I ruined it right but jesse
eisenberg i wouldn't have kept going at
it so calmly that nearly is always
fascinating me because i've seen the
whole thing and every time i watch it
i'm always like yeah but trying to think
of it if it's not a bit why was he so so
so mean to her and I could not figure
out
I just couldn't pinpoint what she did
that caused him to be such a dick to her
I wonder if we look her up if she has an
IMDB page well I thought maybe he was
like doing one of those like jerk
flirting kind of things like he's so
mean you know like a mood I always say
that in movies I haven't seen a
real-life where someone's like that mean
but then she ends up sleeping with him
because a man wrote that movie you seem
very upset and I didn't realize Michael
Jordan was I mean it makes sense with
his legendary basketball career of how
much of a G he would be at dropping the
mic on so many things can you still dunk
are you kidding me I think these are
good clothes because some of them were
just like really funny Mike drops and
some of them or like these persons
really offended that Jerry Seinfeld one
I've always loved that one because
that's where were two right Jerry
Seinfeld's
comedian who I love listening to his
stand-up but he always seems like he
does have such a huge ego yeah I got
this snobbish attitude
I don't know Jerry Seinfeld in real life
I have no idea maybe even the camera's
not rolling he's the nicest guy in the
world
I don't know but whenever I see
interviews smellavision almost every
single time I see you especially right
after everything that happened to her oh
that was Ke$ha I didn't recognize her
that was when she released praying after
she won her case and he did her oh
that's a move I feel like if anyone
wants a hug like anyone who recognizes
wants a hug from you my casino
I've only been recognized by maybe one
female but nearly every guy who's
recognized me I'm like give me a hug I
hope everyone I do my best
can you imagine going up to your Idol
and just wanting a hug I wish I could
deal with mean comments like this well
it's different when it's on the internet
cuz you can't just be like oh it's not
bad act like it's it's it well if I'd be
like a response so like if I'm
live-streaming and someone says
something I can do it the thing is when
I like read a comment and by myself I
feel like if I take the time like this
every once in a while I'll reply
everyone so yeah I'm like human like
everyone else so once in a while I'm
like [ __ ] this guy yeah but most of the
time if I read a mean come that really
gets to me it's frustrating because I'm
like oh man if I was a person or
probably I could say something but it's
not just got those anger buried in me in
there I got I can [ __ ] say anything
are you yeah NORAD let me insult you
that's not how this works
clap back the clock back though they say
yeah clap back come on how many guys
have you given the clap it's the other
way around guys give girls that making
an STD reference my drop oh that was
your insult come on
not an insult of you without realizing
it by saying right you wins you win with
that I'm not gonna but it's interesting
to me I see how guys watching you in
laughs when the guys like just create
your own comedy show and that's how you
win you realize how hard it is to even
like get seen as a few look like you
could have a dope set but just because
you're a female all the times you even
get the opportunity to show it so it
doesn't really work that way buddy
but thanks for well you see like
pretending to know what it's like to be
a girl
I like this compilation because there
are ones where the mic drops I'm like I
so agree with ya and then there are
other ones where I'm like I don't agree
with him you know and also there was
like videos here where it was like Trump
and I'm not a trump supporter that thing
about Rosie O'Donnell that's a funny one
but you know it's like it's like well
you're not even acknowledging the fact
that you did the way you do talk about
women in general though exactly yeah so
there was some like okay that's a mic
drop I'll give you a credit for the
Rosie O'Donnell burn but you didn't
actually address the issue it seems like
may for some of the best SNL skits -
yeah this is a fun video anyway leave
your mic drops down in the comments
below let's see what you all got I say
assault each other and then come back
come back I'm kidding - yeah we're gonna
dedicate our mind to that we're gonna
we're gonna slowly deteriorate to health
just so you guys can leave some comments
subscribe to the react nation click that
notification bow bow Sally on the
youtubes due today
I just posted a new video whoop